Welcome to the second
week of our class
on shaping the future of work.
We got off to a
great start last week
with lots of good discussions
on the future of work,
on your hopes, your aspirations.
A lot of discussion about
the future of technology
and how it's going to affect
work and some of the worries
that many of you
have about this.
So we'll continue
these discussions
we'll go into more
depth on technology
and work down the way in about
the fourth week of class.
But to give you a preview,
I posted a new note
on the discussion board
about a big new MIT project
on the future of the technology
in textiles, of all industries.
We are about to
start a big project
to see if we can put some
of the ideas of this course
to work in practice, where we
shape the future of the textile
and fabric industry
with high technology
jobs, hopefully,
good quality jobs,
with new training programs.
So take a look at that post.
See if you have thoughts on how
we can shape the future of work
in that particular sector.
But this week, we'll
do three things.
First, the videos that
are posted for this week
will give you a bit of a history
of how the social contract
played out and worked well in
the United States and, in fact,
in some other countries
around the world in the past.
We do this not to try to repeat
history but to spring forward
on the basis of a good
understanding of where we've
come from and what we
need to do to build
a new social contract--
a good foundation for
building a new social contract
in the future.
Second, this week we're
going to introduce
some new regional
discussion facilitators.
Our MBAs from the class
I'm teaching here on campus
are from all over the world.
From China, from South
Asia, from Africa,
from northern
Europe, from Brazil.
They will host
discussions about how
the issues we're
talking about play out
in your regions of
the world, and we
ask those of you who
are from those areas
to join that conversation.
We'll even have some new
experts from Australia.
Some colleagues of mine in
the universities over there
who study and work
on these issues.
So I think we'll have a full
body discussion about how
the changing nature
of work is playing out
in different parts
of our planet.
To get things started on
your personal career process,
this week, there's
an assignment that
will take you step by
step through a process
of identifying the
kinds of issues
that you're interested
in, you have some aptitude
toward, and then the kind
of educational levels
that are available to get
access to the jobs in fields
of interest to you.
So get started by going
to the assignment page,
start that process.
It'll carry through over
the next several weeks,
and it's accompanied
by several videos
around the role
of education, it's
changing role in
lifelong learning,
and a special video by our
colleague, Lee Dyer, who
talks about the skills
and competencies needed
for the jobs of the future.
So that's what
we'll do this week.
But before we finish
here, let's take
a look at what you told us
last week about your goals
and your aspirations for work.
Here's the results
of the poll that you
filled in about
your top priority
for your work and your career.
Notice that the
top item comes out
to be having a good
work life balance,
followed very closely
by having a big impact
on problems that are important
to you and to society.
And then in third place
but not too far behind
is the desire to have a
good living from your work
experiences.
These are the same top three
items that your colleagues
last year indicated were
their top priorities,
although this year,
the work life balance
became a little bit
higher in the ranking.
So it's very clear that
you want many things out
of your jobs and your careers.
Unlike your parents,
as many of you
told us who focused over
here on earning a good living
and having a stable
job, you want
to be able to both have
a big impact on work.
You want to have a
good work life balance
so you can have a
good opportunity
to raise your children and
be a good spouse at home
or a partner at home and
also earn a good living.
So let's focus on
how we do that.
Let me give you a
couple of examples
of the rich way in
which you embodied
these rankings in the range
of comments in the exercise
around comparing your goals
with those of your parents.
This one, I think,
captures the essence
of what the poll told us.
As one of you said, "I dream
of a well-balanced work family
environment, where I
can develop my skills
put them to service
for my community,
and as well get a
wage that allows
me to have a decent
life so that I
can provide for my
family and my offspring."
Or this one, "My
dream is to change
the world by contributing
something meaningful to it.
While maintaining a
balanced lifestyle,
I consider myself
a global citizen."
This is something that a
number of you mentioned.
That you wanted to work and
live in a culturally diverse yet
an integrated workplace
and lifestyle,
and that you want to push
your children to be curious
about their world and to
push the limits of what
they can do as they grow up.
Here's another one
that says, particularly
about young millennials
and their interest
in working with the
digital revolution.
"My dream is to be part of
the digital revolution driven
by millennials working
at innovative companies,"
and "to make the world a
better place to live and work."
That theme comes through again.
And then finally, "I want
to earn a living wage
and not have to miss my
children growing up."
This is the world of
work that you aspire to.
This is the world
of work that we
have to create moving forward.
So let's get on with the task.
This week, we'll focus
on your responsibilities
to make sure that you
are prepared to have
the right educational
levels to achieve
your goals and your
aspirations, and then we'll
also look at what
made the world of work
more effective in sometimes
in the past in our countries
so that we can spring
forward to think
about how we build
a new foundation
for the future of work.